- Hey, Addy Hour fam.
Just want to give a little
bit of an introduction
to this episode 29,
this conversation with
Rabbi Angela Buchdahl,
we're actually releasing on
different a day this week,
just with everything that
we've experienced as a society.
I'm recording this intro
on the 26th of May,
and I debated for a while,
on whether to release
the episode this week,
where to give some time
just as we've continued
to experience tragedy after tragedy
with these shootings first, not first,
but recently in Buffalo,
then again in California,
in Texas in elementary school.
And so I debated whether
to release this episode
because some of the
topics that we brought up
were also related to that in the sense
that Rabbi Buchdahl also
walked or has walked through
and helped navigate a hostage situation
at synagogue in Texas in January.
And that's something that she talked about
on the episode as well.
So I just wanted to be sensitive
to where you would be all
or were as a society, where
you all were as listeners,
but ultimately I thought it
would still be good to release
the episode because there's
so many aspects of hope
that she also shared in this episode
in terms of just things
that she has been navigating
as a leader, things that she
has navigated in her synagogue
and in her Jewish community
and I think important lessons for us all.
So again, that's the reason
that we decided to wait
and not release this episode
the day after the tragic shooting.
Our hearts go out to all those families,
not even being able to
imagine what it's like
to lose a child in that type of setting
on such an unfortunate circumstance.
And in so many ways,
obviously there are lots
of policy implications
so we could actually do better
to try and prevent these
things from happening.
So with that being said,
just wanted to make sure
that I put this in context.
I hope that you all
still will take the time
to process and to mourn and
to grieve as you need to,
but also to know that we
are here for each other
and we need to support
each other in this time.
And I think that's something
you'll definitely get
in this episode as well.
But again, just wanted
to put things in context
and to let you all know about that,
but I encourage you to
listen to the episode.
So many important things
that we were able to discuss,
and I believe that
you'll find it cathartic
and healing in some ways as well.
And I appreciate you
all, always being here
as an Addy Hour family and for everything
that you all do to invest in this podcast.
(upbeat music)
Well, welcome to another
episode of the Addy Hour.
I'm grateful to continue to
host these conversations.
I will say on the front end,
we are operating a spirit
of flexibility today
as we've been navigating
some technical challenges,
but again, it's so important
for us to just be flexible
in this moment and something
that I've been saying
to a lot of people.
So it makes sense that
I would have to move
in that space as well.
But again, grateful that
you all continue to join
these conversations, actually recording
in the Yale podcast studio again today.
So thankful for the team
and for all they've done
to really just help us
facilitate these conversations
over the last year and a half.
Today, I'm honored to be able to welcome
Dr. oh my goodness, rabbi,
that's something I've done--
- You elevated me.
- I've done to multiple guests.
You're not the first,
but to introduce Rabbi Angela Buchdahl,
who is here joining us
for a conversation today.
So grateful to have you
here on the podcast.
- Grateful to be here.
- And for today's conversation,
it's just gonna be an open conversation
on a lot of different topics.
I haven't assigned a
specific title or theme,
which is a little bit
different for us, but again,
I think as you all listen
into this conversation,
you'll see why that's the
case because there's so many
important things that we may
touch on as we go through.
So just by way of introduction
for any who aren't familiar
or familiar with the Rabbi,
I just wanted to mention
her background a little bit.
She serves as a Senior Rabbi
of Central Synagogue in New York City
and is the first woman to lead
Central's Reform Congregation
in its 180 year history.
So Rabbi Buchdahl first
joined Central Synagogue
as a Senior Cantor in 2006, and in 2014,
she was chosen by the congregation
to be the senior rabbi.
She was born in Korea to
a Jewish American father
and a Korean Buddhist mother.
Later in life, she attended and earned
a Bachelor's Degree in
Arts and Religious Studies
from Yale University here on campus.
And of course later became ordained
as a first Asian American to be ordained
as a Cantor or rabbi in North America.
So someone who is a
pioneer and a trailblazer
in a lot of ways.
She's been nationally recognized
in a lot of different ways
and also for her innovations
in leading worship,
she's been featured in
dozens of news outlets,
including The Today Show, NPR
and PBS, and was also listed
as one of Newsweek's America's
50 Most Influential Rabbis.
Angela is someone who also serves
on a lot of different organizations,
and boards, on the AGC,
also on the New York Board of Rabbis,
on the UJA Federation of New York
and on the Yale University
President's Council.
She's married to her husband, Jacob,
and they have three children.
So again, someone that
I've been introduced to
and have had the pleasure of being able
to interact with a little bit
and really looking forward
to the conversation this afternoon.
So thanks so much for being here.
- Me too, you left out that
I was the college roommate
of Dr. Esther Choo, who
was our point of connection
to begin with, and my claim
to fame in the doctor award.
(Addy laughs)
- Maybe that's where the
doctor part slipped for me.
- Maybe that's what it was.
- Perhaps, I'm elevating you, but I think,
you know, humor aside,
there are so many things
that you have so much influence
and impact in as well.
So who knows, maybe that's something
that will come as an honorary
at some point in the future,
but I'm starting that today, but yes,
definitely appreciate that
recognition of Dr. Choo
connecting the two of us and
appreciate her investment
in what we're doing here as well.
So again, just to start out, as you know
and as my listeners know,
I think it's so important
for us to have check-ins with each other,
as we engage in some
of these conversations.
And especially as we're
recording at this point in time
in the middle of May,
the third week of May.
Obviously this has been
another challenging week
for our country, even
as we have been mourning
the loss of so many
lives, first in Buffalo
with a tragic situation
there, also in California.
And also just acknowledging
that a lot of these things
are ongoing, even events
that don't necessarily
hit the national news media in a sense.
But at the same time, we have
a lot of room also for joy,
as we see people collectively
supporting each other
in so many different ways,
as we have reasons for hope.
And so with those two things in mind,
just wanted to check in with
you and see how you are doing
at this point in time with everything
that we're navigating
through as a society.
- I think I'm feeling what a lot of people
in this country are feeling,
which is a mix of despair
and deep upset and hurt over recent
devastating gun violence,
racial hatred that we're seeing.
Last two weeks ago, the news
about the leaked decision
about abortion Supreme Court
and where we might be
heading with women's rights.
And there's a lot that we
are very concerned about.
And I think that for me
as a person who works
in the religious field, I think
that spiritual resilience,
like part of the work now
is that we actually keep up
our sense of spiritual
resilience to have the will
to not give into that
despair, to actually believe
and remind ourselves that
change is always happening
and continues to be possible,
change for the better.
And I think that that's
where we are right now,
and I actually have to
keep reminding myself
of that message at times.
- Really well said and I
take that to heart as well,
even in terms of the reminders
that we have to give ourselves.
How would you say that
those in your congregation
are also navigating
through all this as well
in terms of what you've seen in them,
and then also in your role as a leader?
- I think people are experiencing
this on different levels.
Some are taking it very personally,
some are experiencing it
with a great deal of fear
and anxiety, and there are others
that have kind of built up a wall
and actually have stopped
listening to the news,
stopped actually caring.
I don't know, actually
what is more frightening.
We often talk about the
fact that indifference
is one of the gravest sins,
'cause it sort of enables
and allows all of this to happen.
So I don't think there's just
one response that I'm seeing,
and I think there's a
certain kind of process
that people go through when
they're grieving something
or experiencing a trauma of some kind,
that some of these things
are all that for people
and you have to help
people move through it
to a place that is with a
little bit more healing,
a little more productive,
a little more hopeful.
So I think that's the task.
- And I appreciate how
sensitive it sounds like you are
to just all the different
places that people are
and even, to take it a step
further, I think for many of us,
we're also in a lot of
those different places
at different times.
So, at one moment it might be for me,
walking through morning at another moment,
outrage and frustration,
sometimes some despair as well,
like, oh, this is happening again,
are things ever going to get better.
And just knowing that
there needs to be time
and place for all those pieces,
and it sounds like you're
really empathetic to that
and cognizant of that
as you're in such an important
leadership role as well.
So that's definitely
something I appreciate
and I imagine that those in
your synagogue would appreciate
that level of empathy
and awareness as well.
So I just wanted to acknowledge that.
- Thank you.
- So obviously a lot that we're
walking through and again,
just in your role as a leader,
a lot that you also often
have to carry with you,
yourself and as you're
leading others as well.
So I know we'll come back
to that in the conversation,
but I also wanted to take a
step back a little bit as well,
because as I was just
mentioning your introduction
and your path, there's a lot there,
there's a lot of important
components there,
there's a lot of trail blazing there.
And I was just curious if
you'd be willing to share
with our listeners a
little bit about your path
and your journey from growing up
to becoming in this
esteemed role and someone
who is pioneering in
so many different ways,
how did that journey come about for you?
- Well, so much of this
with so much of life
is a product of some
fortunate timing and luck
as well as just I think
people following a calling
if they're able to listen
to what they're sort of called to do.
And so I certainly never
set out as a little kid
to think to myself, oh, I
wanna be a first of anything
honestly, or a trailblazer.
What I was doing was sort of
listening to a call that I had
from a pretty young age,
that I was very attuned
to sort of the spirit of the universe.
And I received in many ways,
my spiritual sensitivity
from my Buddhist mother,
but then I received
a sort of spiritual and ritual vocabulary
from my Jewish father
with the Jewish community
in which I was raised.
So I think that, actually many Jews
are not actually that
comfortable talking about God,
it might surprise you.
It's not like many other faith traditions
in which people very
comfortably talk about it.
But the vast majority of Jews
that are in sort of progressive circles,
at best you could say many of them
are sort of uncomfortable
talking about it.
But so I think my mother
gave me a sense of comfort,
not just talking about God,
but actually being in
conversation with God
on a regular basis.
And then I think, but the fact
that my father and my mother
decided that my sister
and I would be raised
within the Jewish community,
gave us sort of a ritual
yearly structure for holidays
and Shabbat gatherings and
meals and biblical stories
that sort of informed the way
that I walked through the world.
So in some ways, a
foundation was set early.
I'm not a typical path to the
rabbinate as like an immigrant
from South Korea who comes to America,
grows up in a tiny Jewish
community in Tacoma, Washington,
and goes on to lead a large
synagogue in New York.
- Very true (laughing).
- That is an unusual
story, but in many ways,
part of the luck of this
is that I was born in 1972,
which was the year that
the very first female rabbi
was ordained, so it's 50 years this year
that the first woman was ordained,
which in the scope of 3,000
years of Jewish history,
that's just a blink.
And at the same time, there
was not a day of my lifetime
that I didn't think it was possible
for a woman to be a rabbi.
So in that way, I was very lucky.
I was also lucky my parents
were married in 1969,
this was just a year after
Loving versus Virginia,
which meant that interracial
marriage was not outlawed
in some of our states in America.
So here, my parents
were only a year later,
were getting married at a time
when people were still getting accustomed
to the idea of interracial marriages.
And I was fortunate that
their love was not illegal
in any state, by the time they
got married, but only barely.
I was lucky that I was born
at a time when Title IX passed
and it took a place like Yale,
which had only just
right before I was born
a few years before, started to take women,
but for a while, was still
only wanting to keep women
to about 15% of the college
until Title IX came around
and then they were forced to
have to actually go 50/50.
They did not want to go there willingly.
So I think about these kinds
of things that all contributed
to this path that
ultimately I got to be on.
And I recognize how many
shoulders I'm standing on
in order to have been able to be a woman
who could become a rabbi, who
could have a Korean mother,
who could end up leading a community.
And the last thing I'd say
is that the Reform Movement,
which is the progressive
movement of the Jewish community,
made a decision in the late '70s
that they were actually gonna be welcoming
of interfaith families.
For a long time, the policy,
because it's a community
that really values endogamy
and Jews marrying Jews
for Jewish continuity sake.
Its policy used to be,
we're gonna reject anyone
who marries outside of the faith.
If you ever saw "Fiddler on the Roof,"
which is a lot of people's
Jewish introduction,
they literally shiver.
They say the death prayer
for the person who has married out.
It was a controversial
and very brave decision
that the movement took in the '70s to say,
actually, this is not good
for Jewish continuity,
what's gonna be good for our community
is for us to welcome those who marry out.
So I was also coming to
America just at a time
when the Jewish community's
attitudes were changing
towards families, just like mine.
So all of these things
contribute to how I got to be
where I am and it's a confluence
of gender equality issues
that were just coming of
age, racial acceptance
and interfaith and inter-religious
and interracial couples
that were just becoming
acceptable in society,
just as I was being born into a family,
there was all of those things.
So, I recognize that if I'd
been born a generation earlier
or even 10 years earlier,
my life could not be
possible as it unfolded.
So I think about that a lot.
And frankly, because
I'm a person of faith,
I think that there was a sense
of, this is why I'm called
to be in this place right
now, because I could,
and because I think the
generations before me
probably could not.
- Wow, I mean, that's such
a helpful perspective,
as I'm listening to share
all those different aspects,
some may say serendipity,
but I mean, there's so many
that you just listed in terms of timing,
had things been not even the generation,
but five years earlier,
just so many pieces that were in place.
So it's just, I think it's
actually very encouraging
for me to hear how front
and center that perspective
seems to be for you.
I mean, it doesn't sound like
in any sense it's forgotten
or you had to dig deep to pull it back up,
but it's there kind of
on the tip of your tongue
and that you know
exactly how each of these
different perspectives
really paved the way.
- I will be honest with
you, when I got to Yale
in the '90s, I would think of myself
not as like a reluctant feminist
or I didn't quite understand,
why do we still have a women's center?
Like the job of feminism is done.
I feel so naive thinking
about myself that way,
but that was sort of the way I felt then,
because I felt like I could
do anything a man could do.
It wasn't until I got
actually a little bit older
before I started having
kids, hit the glass ceiling
for the first time, that
I actually appreciated
that actually, oh, we still
have so much work to do.
In fact, if anything, I became
the angry feminist in my 40s.
- Wow.
- But I would say the reason in part
that I'm able to reflect on this now
is actually I'm working on a memoir,
and it's funny how you
look back on these things
and suddenly all those pieces
kind of came into place.
And I don't think it took
some maturity, honestly
and some retrospection to actually think
about how many sort of social movements
had to lay the foundation
for where I could be.
And it made me appreciate
that fight so much more.
It made me realize, first of all,
that we're obviously not
done with any of those fights
from feminism to racial justice,
to acceptance across lines
of difference and all of those things,
but it made me appreciate
that first of all,
we've made some progress, even
though we have work to do.
And it made me reflect on
it in a way that I actually,
frankly, when I was younger,
didn't appreciate honestly.
- Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
And I appreciate your
honesty and giving us
that perspective as well, which
this is gonna sound funny,
but I think is hopeful for many
of us as well to feel like,
well, there's always room for growth,
even as you've stated that so importantly,
but some of the things that
you may not have realized
and had to look back on are now so fresh
and clear to you as well.
And again, just in your story,
I mean, there's so many important
elements that are there,
even from the family
dynamic and the empowerment
you had there to some of
the things and movements
that were happening, but I'm also thinking
just in terms of the importance of policy.
I mean, a lot of the
things that you referenced
were policies that were
changed that had direct impact
on your ability to move
forward in certain circles.
That's something that comes
up in so many different ways.
I mean, I can think about
that on the research side
with some of the work that
we're doing, for instance,
around e-cigarettes and how
policy can influence and impact
aspects of health when it comes to youth
who maybe using e-cigarettes,
young people or adults
and all those types of processes.
But even as you mentioned
around all the diversity,
equity, inclusion,
anti-racism, how the policy
can have direct impacts on people's lives.
I think in a lot of different ways,
sometimes we like to acknowledge that
and sometimes it seems like we pretend
that that's not the case,
that these things are just
philosophical conversations
when there's so much more to it as well.
So I mean, so much of what you said
is resonating with me as well
and I'm attempting not
to become too tangential,
but I think it's just, I
mean, everything you share
is such a concrete example of
so many ways that has happened
in your life that has been
beneficial to you as a person,
as an individual who has
grown and has also allowed you
to have so much impact
in so many ways as well.
So I'm just reflecting as you're talking
and kind of piecing all
those things together
and appreciative again, of
the way that you've been able
to just describe that and
already looking forward
to whatever this memoir is,
that you've just referenced as well.
- Well, unfortunately my day job keeps me
from having a lot of time to write,
but I've done a little more
reflection, so that's good.
- Yeah, speaking of the day
job, I'm also just curious,
as you've taken us on
this journey a little bit,
how do people respond to your journey,
both within the Jewish community,
but the community at large,
because I can anticipate
and imagine that were different responses
and reactions in different circles.
And I'm just curious what that was like
from your perspective.
- I think that you have to
have a sense of humor about it.
And I think that when
I was younger, I mean,
there wasn't a single time I could walk
into a new Jewish community
and not get lots and lots of questions
and they could come from
places of genuine curiosity
and welcome, and they could sometimes come
from a place of challenge and ignorance
and sometimes mean spiritedness.
And I think the question
that I got was some variation
of, that's funny, you don't look Jewish,
or, how are you possibly
Jewish or whatever it was.
And none of those things feel
like massively threatening
in any sort of single instance.
But if it's sort of your experience,
every time you walk into a community,
you feel constantly othered,
you feel kind of constantly
like you don't really belong
and like a stranger.
And so there was a certain aspect of that,
that was a defining
feature of what it was like
to walk into a new Jewish community.
That being said, once I was in a community
like my home community in
Tacoma, it didn't take long
before people just saw
me as Angela and as a Jew
and as part of the
community and they were open
to what I could contribute
and how I wanted to be a part of it.
And so, I mean, I think that I obviously
couldn't be a rabbi today if
I didn't get a lot of support
and love and sense of meaning
from people along the way,
mentors, Jewish community
members, like my surrogate aunties
and uncles, and my congregations
who really welcomed me
and were extremely loving.
So, I think that the good news
is you get past that sort of
initial, how are you Jewish?
And then you just establish
yourself in a way.
And so I would say, I'm
now at a stage in my career
where people know who I am
and I don't get the same questions.
And I think I mistakenly
kind of felt like,
okay, well, I'm the senior rabbi
of a large Manhattan congregation
with a lot of Jews of color
within my congregation.
And I thought, okay, well,
since I'm here at the front,
things are all better, right?
Well recently in light of
the George Floyd murder
and just many more conversations,
sort of a national reckoning
that we were all having
as a country around race,
people in my community
came out of the woodwork
and shared their own stories
of racism within the Jewish community.
And I think I didn't appreciate
that their experience
was still so much more
like mine was 20 years ago
and it wasn't enough that
I was the senior rabbi.
There was still ways that our
community was not responding
as I kind of had hoped.
And so I think, I ended up
giving a sermon about this.
I knew that at kind of the
most Holy Day of the Year
when I have the most people
watching on Yom Kippur,
where I have thousands in
my congregation watching,
and then hundreds of thousands
watching on live stream,
I knew I wanted to address
racism in our country
coming off of the summer that we'd had
when George Floyd was murdered.
I didn't realize until
I started to sit down
and write the sermon that
ultimately I had to start
actually with what I
understood was the racism
that was still existent
within our community.
I felt like you have to
start with your own house.
And our own house still had work to do.
And I recognize that this is a muscle
that you have to actually exercise,
a muscle of fighting your biases.
It's not usually coming.
I believe people usually come
from a pretty good place.
I don't think most people are
trying to actually make anyone
feel othered or make them
feel like they don't belong.
They don't understand that
they're questions that often come
out of curiosity or ignorance,
ends up actually having
that impact on people.
And so I realized that I needed
to talk about that first.
And once you actually work on that muscle
in your own community, you
actually start to understand
what it feels like to be
more cognizant of that
in the rest of the world.
So I saw it as something
that was really important
to start with the Jewish community first,
and that sermon had an
impact that I've never had
any other sermon have.
It basically kind of
went viral for a sermon
in the Jewish world.
And I think that it was
hitting at a particular time,
again, timing is everything,
where the community was willing
to think about it and listen,
and it's really shaped
the conversation for our
community, kind of moving forward,
how we're prioritizing
some of these questions.
And I think a sensitivity to
the way that we're responding
and talking to each other
in our own community.
So, I now have a Jews of
color group at my synagogue,
which is not a group that existed before.
And I think that the ideas we
don't wanna remain separate,
but we also wanna have
a safe space to talk
about some of those things
that are still challenging.
And that group, for example,
wanted to have a meeting
and talk post Buffalo about
what it is to be both a person
who might be Black and Jewish.
And there's sort of some of
the hatred that was coming out
of the gunman's mouth was both
this replacement theory idea
of that both is rooted in
deeply antisemitic views,
as well as racist views against Blacks.
So I think that it's been really
a very interesting journey
to think about what this means.
I would say that I credit my community
absolutely for embracing
me and I think ultimately
the people in our community
with all of its diversity,
I mean, ironically, the
one thing I would say
is I think that when I wanted
to become the senior rabbi,
I'd already been in my congregation
for eight years as the senior Cantor
and so I was known in the community.
And I don't think that it
was an issue at all anymore
that I was Asian, but
it was very interesting
that it wasn't issue that I was a woman,
because that was the gap for people.
At the time there was not another woman
leading a large synagogue
in all of New York.
Like there still is not
a woman in Manhattan
leading a synagogue,
that's a large synagogue
and we have a dozen of them.
So I think that there's
still, it's 50 years,
which as I said, feels like a long time,
but it's also not that long
and we just haven't
quite gotten there yet.
And so for them, the bigger leap
was imagining a woman in charge.
They had become comfortable with the woman
in a number two position, but
I think it's very different.
And it came out in
different ways that I felt
when I was applying for that job,
eventually people selected me.
So I think that obviously it wasn't enough
for people to not kind of say,
we're ready to take this leap,
but it's interesting how my
president, who at the time,
said that as soon as it was announced,
we actually happened to go
to a large convention of Jews
called The Biennial
Gathering a week later.
He said he could not believe
how many people said to him,
"What a brave decision you made."
And he thought, "Wow, they're
really characterizing this
"as like, it's brave to
name a Korean female rabbi
"as the head of Central Synagogue."
And so that just gives you
a sense of where that was,
that was nine years ago.
- Yeah, wow, such a helpful perspective,
all the things you've shared
and especially that
last component as well.
But just to go back a little bit,
I mean, I'm impressed and encouraged
one, at your willingness to
lean in, in your own house
and for the ways that
people seem to go along
on that journey with you and
really have that introspection,
'cause even as you were
talking, I was imagining
just ways that people could
react in that situation.
I mean just based on all
the things we've seen,
so many different ways of
denial or 'cause like you said,
even if it's not from a
place of intentional hurt,
that can sometimes put
up a wall and the barrier
where people don't really want
to acknowledge what's there.
So as much as people were willing to lean
into that conversation and
to you to be able to listen
to what people were
bringing to you as well.
But to your last point,
I think that just speaks
of where things are, and
again, this is me speculating,
but you being in this role as a woman
and people trusting you and
entering into that space
with you and walking
through these hard topics,
because obviously they
are difficult challenges
for any of us to walk through,
but it seems like there's
more and more layers there
as they're looking to you as a leader,
but also having to reconcile the fact
that you are one of the few,
especially in your area,
and how that has also
likely had an impact.
I mean, even that comment
about people saying
that was the bravest
decision, it's very reflective
in a lot of ways about
people's perceptions.
And not only like they were
saying that for the president
and whoever was involved
to make that decision,
but it seems like that would
also have an impact on people
being willing to follow in a sense,
not that they're following you,
they're ultimately following
God in the higher power,
but you, in that role as a facilitator.
So again, I'm just kind of
reflecting as you're sharing
all those pieces.
But one other question
that did come to mind
is just, as you mentioned
that there aren't other women
of large synagogues who
are in this same type
of leadership role, what has
that process been like for you?
I mean, is there enough, not
that you don't have a cohort
among your peers, but is that
I won't call it attention,
but I'm just curious, I
guess how that experience
has been for you.
I don't want to pre-label
it or presuppose,
just to kind of give you room
to comment on that as well.
- I guess the good news I would say
is that it really has changed, even since,
I've been in this role
for eight years now,
so since I was named nine
years ago, it has changed.
There's a woman was named
to a large congregation
in Brooklyn and then
soon after up in Toronto.
And so, not yet in Manhattan as many,
although I certainly
have female colleague,
but of like the large communities
that you started to see it
changing in the last
especially five years.
And so that's also been encouraging
and I'm part of a larger rabbi cohort
that studies together
in Jerusalem every year.
And that now has like a real cadre
of like strong women rabbis,
so that's been wonderful.
But I still, when I sit at tables
and especially interfaith tables,
I often am still like the
only woman in the room.
I'm part of a religious
coalition that is organized
by the Cardinal Dolan here in New York
and there literally were
no women at that table.
And I actually opened
my big mouth and said,
"I notice that this is a
coalition of religious leaders,
"you don't have a single
woman sitting at this table
"of your executive group."
So you open your big mouth,
then you get invited,
so I have to show up.
Now there are two of us,
but the fact is that in
many faith traditions,
they still do not have women in positions
of religious leadership with
specific kinds of titles.
And so it's not just about
my own faith tradition,
it's in the larger faith world and space.
There's still real barriers for women,
the stain glass ceiling, we call it.
And I think there's
still a lot of work here
and the implications are
not just that you're losing
50% of the potential
leadership that you could have,
I actually think it's even
more dramatic than that
in terms of what is lost.
I think that people's theology is shaped
by the people who convey the message.
And it's just interesting, I mean, people,
I used to grow up and say
things like, oh, Rabbi Stern,
he was a rabbi of a community
that I used to lead.
His voice was the voice of God,
that's what I imagined
God's voice to sound like.
It was Jack Stern, and believe me,
he was a brilliant preacher,
I could imagine God
sounding like Jack Stern.
But that kind of refrain
of like the voice of God
being their rabbi, just
as the transmitter,
think about what that does
for your conception of it.
Now what's interesting is now
that I'm the senior rabbi,
I don't actually think that people think
that God sounds like me as much as now.
I think actually they understand God
in a totally different way, a
little less like from on high,
I think it's partly generational,
I think it's partly the
way women are perceived
and I don't wanna make
huge generalizations,
but I think that it's
shifted our theology.
It's shifted our religious language,
it's shifted the way we create community.
It's so much deeper
than just whether or not
we can put women in positions.
When you're talking about
spiritual leadership,
it actually impacts the
entire way you actually think
about the life of the spirit.
So I think that it's profound,
the change that's happened
in 50 years since women have entered
the rabbinate in our community.
- Yeah, that's really wonderful to hear.
And it seems like it's just
like, as you mentioned,
just perspective in a lot of ways too.
And so many aspects of, I mean,
when we think about the reflection
of God in the community,
it's not one or the
other, it's all people.
So to hear you to speak about those things
in just the practical
ways you've seen that
is just also encouraging as well.
And I would imagine this
having just generational,
or will have generational impacts as well.
I guess some of that remains to be seen,
but I'm just thinking
forward in that realm as well
and so definitely appreciate the way
that you've brought so many
of those things to light
and then all the work that
you're continuing to do.
'Cause I imagine it's not light work
even as we have already
been talking about.
And on that, I mean, just
balance is a word that I use
cautiously at this point
in time, but I'm wondering
just to kind of move the
conversation a little bit
outside of your specific role,
but also think about how you
attempt to balance or juggle
or manage as it were all
the many different roles
that you have and responsibilities,
even in the midst of the
things that continue to happen,
because you talked about
some of the communities
that you've been involved
in, in your own congregation,
the groups that have started
up, even the conversation
you had the last few days
about the situation in Buffalo.
So how do you manage your
time from that standpoint
to still be able to invest
and serve in your congregation
in the community, but then
also to be able to have people
pour into you as well.
- Balance, I think what
does that word mean?
I think the image that comes to mind
is like being on one of
those like little seat
of like those Teeter-totters,
where like you put your leg
on each side and like,
the idea that you get
to a point of balance, maybe
you're like, "I got it."
And then you're immediately back and forth
and like the entire time all
you're doing is adjusting.
I think that's kind of what
I think my balance has been,
like, it's just constantly adjusting.
Every once in a while, I can
have a moment where like,
"Ah, I'm in balance" and then it's back.
So, I think, I don't know if
that's what I'm going for,
I think I wanna be able to feel
like at the end of the day,
the things that I have paid attention to,
which is ultimately gonna be
what my life is made up of,
that those are the things
that I wanted to have paid attention to.
And I've gotten better about
calendaring that into my life
so that like, I actually
make sure that I calendar in,
my daughter's like basketball game,
and then if that's in there
that I'm not just programming
around or scheduling over it,
that I actually, make sure I
have time for my meditation.
That is part of my own personal practice
or going and exercising a little bit
so that I can have like
mental and physical health.
So I think that what
I've gotten better about
is scheduling that and working my life
to make sure that those elements in.
Sometimes it has to get canceled,
sometimes it has to get moved,
but it's that constant work.
One of the things I have
come to understand better
and it probably took
till about 10 years ago
when I finally started doing
more spiritual practice work
and meditation is I
used to think of things
like taking care of myself.
Self-care has like all
sorts of connotations.
It can sometimes be problematic,
but I used to think of it
as in way sort of indulgent.
And I went on my first sort
of spiritual practice retreat
with the Institute for
Jewish Spirituality,
I guess it's already like 10 years ago,
five days, mostly silent
meditation retreat
and with some learning and some yoga
and a lot of meditation.
And it was like a revelation for me.
It sort of helped me understand
that when I am actually not
feeling in some ways whole,
I've got nothing left to give in some way.
And so I started to understand
that caring for myself
is a form of caring for
God, caring for others.
And so I don't feel as
apologetic for making that time
that I think I used to in my younger days,
feel much more that way.
It's still hard to find finally,
and I think that's continued work.
- Yeah, well, I appreciate
you sharing that as well
'cause I think so many
people have started to pay
a bunch more attention to
that, and it's just refreshing
and encouraging to hear you stating that
as a leader as well,
just knowing how important that time is.
I mean, one humorous example
I always share with people
is just the lack of a
commute for me personally
and not realizing how much
of that I use for processing
when that commute turned
into the one minute commute
from the attic makeshift
office, back to home life
and homework and all the other things
that come with that realizing,
just feeling like things
were more frazzled.
And so no, oh, that
wasn't having that time
was actually helpful and I didn't realize
how much I was using
it to process and reset
and just have balance
in that sense as well.
So you hear you talk about those
retreats that you've taken,
how important that is, and
then just even thinking
from a biblical reference standpoint
to if our bodies are temples
and are we actually taking care
of our temples or just output,
output, output all the time
with no care for that.
So I appreciate you walking
us through that as well
and it's the importance of scheduling,
sometimes it makes it
feel, I guess, less, well,
it is less spontaneous
and less meaningful,
but I think at the end of
the day, like you mentioned,
it just important to have those pieces
and to know that there is meaning
that comes from that
intentional scheduling
of that basketball game for your daughter
and how important that is for both of you.
So, definitely appreciate you taking--
- Well, I mean, and I think this wisdom
of just the importance
of some of that time,
I mean, that is a foundational
principle of Judaism
that we are actually not
meant to work day in, day out
and create every day of the week.
We actually have to take rest
and Shabbat is actually
not just utilitarian
so that we can rest up so
we can go back and work,
it's actually the point of it all.
And I would say that
maybe the most profound
spiritual practice of my life
is that I really do make
Shabbat for myself and my family
and that has sustained us.
Even though in my field of
work, I work on Friday nights
and lead services, to me
though leading services
is when I'm in the flow
and I find tremendous joy
and that does not feel like
the work of my job at all.
And this Saturday morning,
I often am leading services,
although I'm also off some,
because I have a big team
and we share the responsibilities.
So, but Saturday afternoon
we are almost always
having a long leisurely unencumbered,
Shabbat lunch with other families,
with our whole family with no electronics.
And it is luxuriousness of space and time
and nothing scheduled.
And I think there is
something about the boundaries
of like, I can't do
anything else, but just be,
that actually creates tremendous freedom.
And there's such wisdom,
I think if I could encourage everyone
and I don't mean just
people who are Jewish,
but all people to truly
feel bound to take one day
without creating or doing
or feeling ambitious,
but just to feel like this moment,
I don't have to do anything,
but just be with the people
I love, exist, enjoy, take
joy is life changing really.
- Yeah, I 100% agree with you
and appreciate that reminder
for all of us and the importance of it.
And again, just impressed with
how, 'cause it is discipline
the way that you're talking about as well,
making that disciplined.
- Yeah, it actually
takes discipline.
In some ways, I didn't
grow up in a tradition
where I felt that that was
my religious obligation,
I grew up in a less
kind of observant home.
And I actually, there's a part of me
that was very jealous of
people who felt like commanded
by God in that sort of
traditional way to like not work.
And it took me a while to get
to the place of recognizing
that that commandedness was
real and can come internally
and you can decide to take
your life in that way.
So many of us feel like we don't
have control over our lives
that way, I think we have
to push back on that.
- Yeah, yeah, 100% agree.
And just the life and the
freedom that comes from that.
Even from neuroscience
plus the expectation,
we can look forward to
that and have that control
and just all the ways that,
I mean so many aspects
of what you talked about
just even being in community
with one another in that
space and in that time,
without all the outside
pressures and just how beneficial
that is for us as human
beings, as God's creation
and just what it does to be in community.
I mean, I'm trying not
to pull in all the things
from our previous episodes
with oxytocin and community,
but all of that is there as well.
I'll let people listen
to previous episodes
to really dig deep into that,
but it's so refreshing in some ways.
Even in these conversations
that we have to see
so many of these things come
from different components,
from what we know from
our faith traditions,
from what we know and are
learning from the neuroscience
or psychology and to
know that these things
are for our benefit, and there's a reason
that we should strive to
keep those disciplines.
- I love that, I kind of geek
out on finding out the science
that supports the thing
that religious tradition
has been telling us to do all along.
I love that, it just kind of
confirms the wonder of this,
but I think it's part of it
is that you have to imagine
a religious tradition that has evolved
over thousands of years.
And I think it really truly does exist.
Its purpose is to kind of
help shape people's lives
as lives of meaning and value and purpose
and also help reinforce community,
which is so deeply important.
I think in a time when
people feel more isolated
than they've ever felt, more lonely,
lacking meaning and direction,
I think that religion is the antidote.
I mean, I think spirituality for me,
it's not just about believing in God.
In fact, it doesn't have
to be that language,
which I recognize has a
lot of baggage for people.
I think maybe one of the best explanations
I've heard and I don't
know where I heard this,
so I'm sorry I can't quote
it, but I'll share it,
is that the opposite of
spirituality is not atheism
or ignorcissism, the
opposite is narcissism.
So if a spiritual life is
really, truly to help you
get out of your own head, to
help you actually understand
you are part of something
much bigger than yourself,
you're part of a bigger story.
You are obligated to
something beyond yourself,
that to me is the entire purpose
of what a spiritual life should be.
And I think every faith
tradition offers structure,
ritual teachings for that.
I think every religious tradition
can be corrupted as well
and can be taken to extremes.
But I think every faith
tradition offers the ability
for each human being to
really find their purpose
and understand themselves
out of the smallness
of their individual
life and in the context
of something eternal and much bigger.
- Yeah, so well said, yeah, 100% agree.
And it's just again, so
refreshing and beautiful
to hear you speaking about that as well
and all the ways that we
really need to continue
to move that conversation forward.
And as you mentioned, especially some part
of something bigger and
part of a larger community,
you know how important
that is for so many of us,
especially, even as we
let off this conversation,
just saying that we have seen
aspects of ways communities
have come together in the
midst of the challenges
that we are facing and ways
that it was more difficult
for us to do that when
we were in isolation.
So again, I'm hoping that
we hold onto those aspects
and we don't forget those
things, as we are back in society
in a sense or emerging or reemerging
or whatever state people are in,
because there's a whole
range of different states
that people are walking through that.
But I think is such an important thing
for us to be able to hold
onto in so many ways.
And also this makes me think of unity,
the importance of unity.
I mean, especially, I
know I keep harping back
to what happened in the
past week, but it's been,
I think an opportunity
for us to have unity,
I've even seen some
things on social media,
just talking about well opportunities
for those in Jewish communities and Black
and brown communities
and other communities
to come together around some
of these unfortunately common,
tragic situations that many
of us are walking through,
especially even in Asian American
and in Pacific Islander
communities and the diversity
that that community has,
but what are the ways
that we can kind of move together in union
to make sure that these
things are addressed head on,
even as you've talked about
in your own congregation.
So I know that's different
than what we've been saying,
but that still comes to mind when I think
about these aspects of community.
And I think about these
aspects of having discipline
to sit down and to pause
and to rest and refresh
and just be in the
presence of one another.
So again, it makes me think
that this is just full circle
in a lot of ways.
At the same time, even as you're talking
about some of these disciplines,
and I know that there are
often things that do come up,
I mean, situations come up that throw us
from that disciplined arena.
We have to have margins for
flexibility and adjustments
for impromptu conversations
and those types of things.
So it's gonna have you
share about how that happens
in your life as well, but
also just want to highlight
for those who don't know,
a very specific situation
where that happened for
you back in January,
when you received a call from a gunman
who had congregants in a
hostage situation in Texas,
and how you responded to that situation
in a very quick thinking manner.
So I wonder if you just as much as going,
kind of take us through
that and what you learned
in that moment, 'cause
again, obviously something
that wasn't planned that didn't fit
into your normal routine, but
that you had to respond to.
And also I would imagine to decide
how urgent is this in actuality?
- Well, I received a
voicemail on Shabbat afternoon
after services from a
rabbi who let me know
that he was being held
hostage with three others
by a gunman who had bombs and had a gun
and was threatening their lives.
And he asked for me to call them back.
It took me a few moments
to even figure out
if this was real, did
a quick Google search,
tried to see if there was
anything in the news yet,
which there wasn't at that point.
But realized very quickly
I needed to actually
call this person back.
The rabbi picked up the phone
and then quickly passed
the phone to the gunman
who I realized very quickly,
this was not a crank call,
that this was real and terrifying.
And essentially the gunman took hold
of a really age old anti-Semitic trope
that Jews kind of basically
control government
and control others and
have outsized influence
the sort of, kind of
conspiracy theory model
of Jewish power.
And he called me, he had
done some internet research
maybe because I lead Central Synagogue,
and Central sounds like
it's sort of the center,
he's from England and in
England they have a chief rabbi.
I think he was looking for the equivalent
and he saw a picture of me
when I went to the White House
pictured with Obama.
So he was like, you know the
president, you know Obama.
Honestly, I'm not really
sure why he picked me,
but he believed, he believed
that I could free a person
he called his sister, although
she wasn't his sister,
but a terrorist who had been
convicted and was sitting
in a federal prison 20 minutes
from that synagogue in Texas.
And so he basically gave
me an hour to free her
and bring her to the synagogue.
And he said, "If you do that,
then everyone can stay safe
"and if you don't, well, I have a bomb
"strapped in my backpack and
I've got bombs in New York
"and I have bombs in Brooklyn."
Wasn't sure about the bombs
in New York and Brooklyn,
but I was quite certain
that this man had a gun
and probably a bomb with him
and that he was prepared to
die, that was very clear.
He said that on the phone several times,
"I love death more than you love life."
And I mean, it was a surreal
terrifying responsibility.
I felt completely responsible
for these four people's lives
even as I knew in my mind
that I was mostly
powerless to do anything.
The little that I could
control was buying some time,
hoping to keep him calm, making assurances
until someone could come and save them,
which I thought could be quick,
because I had already heard
that police were on the scene there.
As the situation
unfolded, it took 11 hours
before they actually freed themselves
with the rabbi throwing
a chair at the gunman
and running out the door
and the FBI coming in
and ultimately killing the gunman.
So it was a really unreal situation.
I think that it made, I think
every Jew around the world
felt that they were held hostage
for those 11 hours with them.
I mean, we were watching
in a wait from Israel,
the France to everywhere in
America, I think it was...
And I think that many Americans,
you didn't have to be Jewish
to feel the terror of that,
the horror of his demands.
And I think it's pretty clear
there's a man who suffered
from some mental illness,
which his family concurred,
but he was spouting out
like antisemitic trip,
which he had learned,
and which is too much,
not just in the air,
but too much in the news,
it's been mainstreamed these ideas.
And that was part of
what was so frightening.
I think I felt personally very
vulnerable in those moments.
Certainly not as much as the four
that were being held hostage,
but, and I think that we're
still processing what it means,
I think, to live in a
world, which is like that.
And some of that same
kind of antisemitism,
which fuels white supremacy
is some of the stuff
that is being spouted by
the gunman from Buffalo,
that like, I think for us to think
that that kind of rhetoric
doesn't turn violent,
is to not look at history
and to not be honest with ourselves.
So this has to be the kind of thing
that is not just, it has to be wiped out
immediately upon hearing it.
And I think there's been
way too much acceptance
of this kind of rhetoric
and under the guise
of sort of free speech.
I think it's very threatening.
- Yeah, well, first of
all, I just appreciate you
taking us through that as well.
Obviously that was a difficult situation
while it was happening, I
imagine not necessarily easy
to kind of walk through it again,
but just want to acknowledge
that first of all,
but then also just to
thank you for just sharing
the important lessons with us as well,
especially as we've
talked about the rhetoric,
because again, it so has
so many practical outputs
and outcomes, even in the
same way that we talked
about on the other side,
just the impactfulness
of the policies that allows
you to walk into the role
that you are in a lot of ways
now, but on the other side,
the power of the rhetoric that
can do the complete opposite
and lead to loss of life.
So, I mean, I think it's
really important and healthy
for us to kind of hold
both of those together
and just to think about
ways that we can continue
to move forward.
So I know appreciate you being
willing to go to that level
and just all that you did
in that situation as well.
I mean, just the quick
thinking and having to process
and navigate simultaneously
is not an easy place to be.
- Well, I mean, but part
of what you're lifting up,
which I think is a thread that
I hadn't really thought about
as much is just, we often think
of any of these situations,
whether it's me being
kind of like, oh, look,
there's like the first Asian
rabbi and she's a woman.
And it's sort of like,
almost like an unusual case.
And on the flip side,
it's sort of the negative,
you take someone like this gunman,
you say he's like a lone wolf,
he's this crazy one singular
person who does this.
What we actually often ignore
are the systemic underpinnings
that allow either the kind
of maybe exceptional case
in a good way, or the
exceptional case in a dangerous,
violent way that it's almost,
no one is a lone wolf.
There are systems and biases and tropes
and all sorts of stuff that
kind of like inform a person
that gets them to that place.
So I think that with the Buffalo
shooter, with this gunman,
he acted alone perhaps in that moment,
but he did not come to his
views, which were so dangerous.
I mean, both of those guys
were absolutely pre-meditating their acts.
One drove 200 miles to the grocery store.
This one came all the way from England
and bought an airplane ticket
and worked his way down
to that specific synagogue
that was the closest synagogue
he could find to the prison
that he wanted to free the prisoner from.
So like it was highly premeditated.
So even if it was singular,
there was a whole structure around him
thinking that this was what he had to do.
He didn't go to the church that was close
to that federal prison,
he went to the synagogue
for a very specific reason.
So I think that, like
those kinds of things
that we have to think about,
and it can happen in the positive way too,
that you can have cases that come up.
But I know that I was
supported by a whole structure
of policies and mentors and communities
that sort of like taught
me and helped me understand
what was possible and then enabled
all those things to be possible.
So anyway, those things matter.
- Yeah, that's really well said.
And in a sense it puts onus of all of us
as members of our communities
to think about the influence
that we have with every
single person around us.
I mean, I often talk about
that if I'm giving a talk
around mental health advocacy.
'Cause I think we don't often
all think about ourselves
as influencers because that
word has been so misused.
- Corrupted, yeah.
- I don't know if I wanna go
there, but at the same time,
I often try and challenge
people to think about,
well, who are the people
immediately around you
and how do they react when you
talk about specific things?
So obviously I'm often painting that
in terms of mental health,
but how do you talk about mental health?
Do you talk about it pejoratively
and does that rub off on those around you?
Do they also talk about it that way
so that when someone now runs
into a mental health challenge,
it's seen as completely negative
because that's the culture
and the atmosphere that
we've talked about that in.
And I think you're saying
that in the same way as well
versus do we talk about things
in ways that are hopeful
or informed by truth and healing
and opportunities for community,
because all that will have effects.
And sometimes, I mean,
that can be too late
to think about all the time,
but I think we're oftentimes ignore that.
I mean, myself, I can
think about that as well.
We often ignore that
and we just need to pay
that much more attention to it,
to think about all the lives
that we're influencing around us,
because it will have
these larger implications.
And I think everything that
you've shared on both sides,
has really highlighted that as well.
So a lot for us to think about, and again,
just, I guess I'm feeling
also at the same time,
it's challenging 'cause I feel grateful
and then also a weight of responsibility.
In a sense, I'm grateful
because I feel like,
and this is gonna sound
like self-promotion,
but just the ways we've been
able to do that on this podcast
with so many people who
have been able to share
the ways that they're
having impact locally,
in their families and their communities,
but then also on much larger
scales and nationally as well.
And just as much as we
can continue to elevate
both the small and the big
things that are happening,
I think are just important for us.
And I feel like you've been doing that
in this conversation
too, just even in the way
I keep going back to the
things that you mentioned
about the Shabbat and just the community
and the piece that's there.
I mean, I almost in a sense,
and this is my, sorry,
it's my addiction related
research coming out again,
but I feel like I have a craving
for that type of atmosphere
and that environment
and thinking about ways
to be more proactive about
trying to include aspects of that
in my own life, because
it's easy for that to slip
without that discipline
and dedication as well.
So again, a lot of full circle moments
to them having in this
conversation as I'm just reflecting
on many of the things that
you're sharing as well.
I did also just wanna end
just talking a little bit
about hope because we've
alluded to it a lot
as we've been going
through the conversation,
you've talked about things
that have been given you hope
even in your role and
amongst your confidence,
but I'm curious just what
that word means to you
on a day to day basis, in
the midst of everything
that we experience and in the midst
of everything that you do.
- Well, I ended my sermon
the week after Colleyville,
sharing a blessing that
is part of our tradition.
And it is a blessing that we say
before we read from the
Book of Lamentations.
Lamentations that maybe the
saddest book of the Bible,
and it's about Jerusalem
being sacked and destroyed.
It uses imagery of like
a woman that's soiled,
it's a terrible, terribly horrible piece.
And it is read before the
ninth day of the month of Av,
which is the day of the destruction
of not only the first temple,
but also the second temple.
And then just as the way that
kind of like, I don't know,
religious coincidence works
like many other horrible things
that have ever happened
to the Jewish people
have happened on the ninth day of Av.
So it's kind of a national day of mourning
historic and current.
And we read that Book of
Lamentations on this horrible day,
thinking about all the terrible
things that have happened
to the Jews.
And before we read that
Book of Lamentations,
we say a blessing, at
least in my community.
And we say that we are
(speaking in foreign language)
we are captives of hope.
Like it's such an amazing phrase, captive,
when you're captive to something,
it's almost like you're
being held against your will.
And despite yourself and there are times
when it's very easy for
me to feel very hopeful.
I'm a generally optimistic
person, and then there are times
where I feel like it's actually impossible
and yet I'm a captive of hope.
I think that that is what
we're called to be in a sense.
The text, I think, is
originally from Jeremiah,
but that phrase, but this
idea that we have no choice,
but to be held to that
expectation and we cannot give in
to the kind of the fashion
of the day to despair,
you can't afford that.
So I think that that's my general take,
sometimes it comes more
easily than others.
- Yeah, I love that phrase
and I'm definitely gonna
carry that with me.
Out of this conversation,
hopefully keep that in my spirit,
so to speak.
So again, I appreciate everything.
- I sense you're a kindred
captive of hope, Nii.
- I will take that, I
will definitely take that.
And I think that it's
true in a lot of ways.
And honestly, having people
like you on this podcast
has been a general reminder of that.
And as people have shared
their reasons for hope
and the ways that
they've seen things move,
the ways that people have allowed them
to remain in that place.
And so I definitely take
that and accept that as well.
So, well again, on that note,
just wanna thank you for taking the time,
especially with all the responsibilities,
the role that you have and the things
that you continue to do.
I really appreciate, one, that
we were able to be connected
through Dr. Choo, and two,
that you took up that offer
to connect and just talk
through this conversation
and we've touched on so
many important things.
And I do say this every once in a while,
but this is one of those conversations
I know I'm just gonna have
to go back and listen to,
and just pull out so many
different pieces and reminders
that we've had along this conversation.
So definitely appreciate you being here,
joining on the Addy Hour.
And I know the listeners are gonna get
a lot out of this conversation as well.
- Thank you so much for having me.
- Of course.
(upbeat music)